okay guys let's start what do you think
is this aircraft
taking off I just have to move why okay
but flaps can be down on takeoff as well
yeah it's very hard to tell from this
image yeah probably its its landing but
because there is a gap between the wings
and and the flap and it happens when the
flaps have worked very high how highly
sat so this is in Boeing 777 800 landing
probably this is 787 trying to stop on
the runway you can see the flaps are
down and air brakes speed brakes are
deployed and thrust versus as well the
transverse has just pushed the air in in
the direction of the movement of the
aircraft and what's this
not so good
this is Turkish Airlines flight 1951
25th of February 2009 the there was a
fault
40 radio altimeter on onboard and the
crew didn't take a good reaction so in
fact they just crashed when a half
kilometers but just before in front of
the runway it was the approach to
Schiphol Airport what we are going to
talk today is how we can prevent these
kinds of things but you can't prevent
these things of these things of
happening because it's due to pilot
error or faulty radio altimeter is the
different instruments but you can do
something else you can see the black box
you see this is orange usually people
think that it's black but it's in fact
orange because you you want to easily
spot it in nature because nature is
usually blue and green so not so many
orange things in nature it's red orange
and this is real real image of a black
box so my colleague and myself ruff and
me we're going to try to tell you how we
do this how we try to prevent these
things of happening and we are going to
do whatever we can to do that so the
first I'll tell you something about what
the flight data monitoring is
then I'll teach you how to become flight
data analyst in one minute you'll see
some real data coming from black box and
we'll talk about just a bit about engine
health monitoring and we'll pose the
problem and hopefully we'll bring ruff
on the stage and he'll salute solve the
problem we're not sure but we'll try to
do that okay it's very hard to condense
everything in the aviation just one
presentation so flight data monitoring
is just what the title is saying to you
that you have to monitor your flights
why you want to find deviations from the
safety operation so the idea is to make
flying safer it should be non-punitive
because you can have a sensation of
brick bigbrother sensation because the
pilots have to give away their data in
fact they don't do that voluntarily
it's a mandatory thing so looking at how
they fly the planes so imagine when
looking at your data coming from your
car and you just say ok you are sacked
because you just had a like you spit it
up on the motorway so you shouldn't be
punitive and you will run out of pilots
very soon if you do that and it's data
is very very very confidential quite
sensitive data and the problem is that
it's sometimes it belongs to pilots
sometimes it belongs to the airlines but
you don't want to disclose any kind of
such data it's very very confidential
you can do that just in case of accident
serious accidents so this is Airbus 320
a sketch of Airbus and there's an
important unit mounted on its ends
called flight data acquisition in it and
this is the place where all the sensors
wiring is coming and from this unit by
using wires the data stored in the
aircraft black box what do you think
where the eye box is on this aircraft
yeah who said that okay thank you so the
flight data recorder can be anywhere
it's usually in the tail section of the
plane but now the problem is we would
like to analyze that data and to find
insights from the data and see okay
these pilots are not doing these things
properly but not the pilots we don't
want to blame the pilots
it's our operation how we set it okay
but the problem with this is that it
would be very expensive to you just take
the black box of the aircraft and to get
the data out and put it back so you
don't want to ground the aircraft but we
all we all live in the world of very
tight profit margins in Airlines so you
don't want to ground the aircraft for
that so we have something else this is
quick access recorder it's a small thing
device mounted behind the crew in the
cockpit and it just uses the camera card
to collect the data it's completely the
same data that's coming to data
acquisition unit it just splits into two
bits and pieces the idea is that you can
easily just take out the the card and
upload it to a server and we can analyze
that data yeah
data acquisition is just electronic with
a box that collects the signals you
first you have to collect the signals in
one place then you will distribute this
by wires to fry data recorder you have
to have thing that first you you can't
feed the flight data recorder with all
the buyers 5,000 parameters of 2000
parameters sorry
so first you have to condense these 2000
parameters and then just use one wire to
put it into flight data recorder okay so
how we do this
the first you have to have an aircraft
flying taking off flying and landing and
the latest copy to service it can be
done automatically wirelessly some
airlines do that but you can also as I
told you you can just take out the card
and just upload the data on the service
then data cleansing oh there is nonpoint
masterrace there's some Python so yeah
okay and sorry but this is a very very
time-consuming process because and you
know that you're the data people so it
can take very very much time and then
the data is being analyzed by the
software it's in highest in-house
software and then we detect the events
on the aircraft so one of the events can
be hard landing so the crews just
smashed into the ground and there was a
value of two point zero g and passengers
were not so they were reluctant to say
that that was a smooth landing so we do
these kinds of things so but yeah this
is just to break the the presentation
into two parts but since you've already
had lunch I put this one but by no
chance this is I I don't try to
advertise Java here you say there so but
it's everything is written in Python
okay now I promised you that I'm going
to try to to make a data analyst PI data
analyst of you in just one minute so
what I'm showing you at the moment is
the flight profile this is the altitude
profile and you can see that at 3:51 the
aircraft was on the ground in
goes up crews and landing okay now we
see that there is an event here around a
quarter past five and I'm going to
enlarge the the the axis I'm going to
zoom in that data so the shaded area is
this this area and I'm going to give you
two parameters airspeed and altitude and
I also I'm going to give you engine
power just disregard anyone it's dead
the red line is one engine the red green
one is the other engine what do you
think it happened here I'll give you 30
seconds to do 245 seconds time but what
what was the value minimum value of
artitude no it's about 300 feet sorry
for the scale yes it went go around it
was too low altitude to say that they
were you know cute very cute you don't
do that at such low altitudes the lower
to the ground you are the rescue
operation is so you don't do these kinds
of things
it was the go-around so the what crew
did it just pushed the throttles up and
accelerated and there is another
parameter pitch so this is the angle
with respect to horizontal surface so
they're pitching up adding full power
above 100 and the aircraft goes up and
you can see these smooth lines so it's
not instantaneous
then just need some time to react to
your commands in table this is the data
you will see that pitch is fifteen point
one so it's marked at a red event
because you're not pitching in 15
degrees when you land usually want to go
steady route down and the other thing
the energy power was above hundred
percent percentage of normal values can
be fear above hundred percent but it's
yeah so it's it's yeah very much power
put into the system so this is an two
exceedance of just power exceedance and
this was marked as a go round event and
in fact it was it go around we don't
know from this data why was it due to
bad bad weather or something else
this is what was this hopefully it's not
an engine of an aircraft yeah but this
is an old agricultural steam engine but
for those of you who like jet engines
there's a schema and since we all here
from data land we can abstract those
things you don't have to know airspace
dynamics of things that have love-love
to understand this so the interesting
bit is just just look at the colors
there is a green color shaft and it's
called low-pressure shaft and it's
characterized by one number now rotation
speed okay we are abstracting the
parameters there's another one and two
the the purple one
this is the high high pressure shaft and
you have to put something so you were
putting your producing pressure in the
engine and then you have to put some
fuel and this fuel burns and you have
exhausted gas temperature to simplify
things I'm just going to disregard these
first two parameters because we are
going to play with the model but just
fuel flow and exhaust engine temperature
exhaust gas temperature temperature so
these two are in play if you have four
engines or two end yeah usually you have
two but if you have four engines then
you can keep pairs of parameters
together so now you have eight
parameters you don't have just two
parameters so this redundancy will help
you to lower the variance in the result
what happens it to take off fuel flow is
about 500 liters per kilograms per hour
and it's steady there so probably
aircraft is on the ground you see
picture zero so the slope is zero just
sitting at certain point it will get to
takeoff clearance from the ATC and then
when they get to take of clearance they
will put some power to the engines and
you'll see some time needed for this to
go up so fuel flow starts here and goes
up while they're accelerating down the
runway so you get the maximum fuel flow
but they're still on the ground you said
that pitch is zero
after that takeoff happens approximately
here then because pitch is going up
there pitching there rotating aircraft
which is the nose and goes up
the interesting baked hair after 20
seconds into the flight the crew presses
the V nav button so this is vertical
navigation yes some people think okay
who is flying the plane usually they
will just press the button and the
computer will try to adjust so they are
taking off because it's very risky to be
lower to the ground and we still believe
humans are better for some some people
will not agree on that but what it's a
pilot that pitches the aircraft but at
certain point he says okay computer take
over and the computer takes over what
happens as a result of that computer
thinks that it has to maintain lower or
higher speed and it will adjust the fuel
flow to have an optimal performance
takeoff or whatever that means so in a
few seconds time in fact you will see
this drop in fuel flow because the
computer will try to accommodate for the
new situation and it happens just a few
seconds after the autopilot was engaged
and we want to detect this point okay
and it's a big problem if this point is
not detected properly we'll have a
protocol problem which end engine health
because during takeoff higher values of
power are allowed you are not allowed to
have 100% power in cruise ok so if you
if you just disregard this point then
you might miss the opportunity to see
that something is wrong how the engines
are handled so the parts are using too
much fuel too much power and you will
have they will have to go to maintenance
too early and this is losing money in
fact and compromising flight safety so
it's extremely difficult we try to do
that deterministically so with a
classical signal processing so
differentiation of signal the signals
are very much different and they vary
across very different aircraft families
the third problem was what if a
parameter fails you have eight
parameters recording and helpless
aircraft and 105,000 approximately on
one hundred and five hundred one
thousand five hundred parameters on
Airbus 380 and then you just can't it's
the parameters will fail but it's not
that the aircraft can't fly
okay so it happens all the time so we
have problems with missing data we have
to handle it very frequently and this
kind of you have to retrain the model
make it break a different model
another dependency tree if you if your
parameter fails if you don't use
statistical approach for that so the
solution is just use the V enough when
the octopus was engaged and try to find
the the drop or raising fuel flow and
exhaust gas temperature and we'll try to
find the changes around those times to
mark the point correctly well gather the
knowledge and try to calculate the
probability for the end of takeoff or an
unseen flight so these three parameters
are in the game and now ruff will
continue with Matt he asked me before
this presentation you just tell to
people that we are going to do some
Python so I've just forgot so you'll
have to
just
okay so as Mark introduced it I will be
talking about the detection of the end
of the cough point how
how we're gonna do this it's we will be
using probably a probably sick approach
and we will have a mortar that is valid
certainly depart first parties we've
gonna have a probably stick approach and
in the second part we don't have a
data-driven approach essentially we want
to collect the probability distribution
from a number of flights and then apply
apply all the probabilities that we have
collected and to predict the end of the
component for the new testing flight
what's the main it will gonna be it's
going to be of course by Donna and okay
it's gonna be Python with the Sun that
classical libraries numpy step I psyche
to learn and we're gonna use PI MC so if
you're following any course I need to
Taurus or any other conference II any
other the talks you know a bit of
primacy I I can give how we give a very
short presentation of that but first of
all let's talk about the data as Marco
say that we have the data in our server
that is solid as an HTM file and in
order to you to load the data and export
the data we use the our funded access so
that is an open source tool and it's
world of mind is on the top this is a
screenshot of the documentation page as
you see one main point is about the
MOSFET device and that's it's very
important to
we have the mass catalyst of telling us
if someone if a certain parameter is
failing and how many times this
parameter is failing as an example of
what use our hdf are access there are
many ways you can subclass our hdf file
you can use the width heat that is very
pathological and you essentially
excessively does a normal pattern
dictionary now all the data each
parameter is recorded at the different
frequency for example the normal G is
recorded eight samples per seconds
whereas the peach is recorded a sample
per second before we have resolved to
align each of them and in this example
among each of them at frequency one and
it is an example of showing the beach
and a one and one that is the power of
the first engine and as you see before
the second 500 there is a piece of
missing data that's that happens not so
readily and when that happened we really
don't want to use that data in order to
fit our properly sick model
what's the strategy we have a as I said
before we have a two-step model for
Seoul we create our probability model we
fit the model so we collect the
parameters that we want we detect the
vertical navigation engaged and we just
look for a window around the vertical
navigation engagement progress we know
that the end of the curve it will up and
around that point we run our model
collect samples for each flight and then
we will collect all the samples and we
use those sample to predict the end
probability for different flights why we
have a different a two-step model
because not all the flights and the
vertical navigation and because
sometimes the vertical navigation may
just fail as parameter what happened sir
hold it go to the yeah I went through
the the JavaScript that have been laid
out to Jess yesterday night but we have
to swap this so I probably made the I
this is the old JavaScript
okay that's fine so here I just want to
present a very simple model and we're
gonna use just two parameters the fourth
row and it was first temperature for
only one engine and essentially what
happens at around uber trio navigation
those two parameters are a piecewise
constant there will be a drop at some
point and that drop will be with us to
the end okay cough so we want an Center
when that happens the data that those
parameters are time series we want to
find the distribution probability that
each point is the end of the curve point
the ketone will be PI MC that
essentially is a very powerful utility
to run a Markov chain Monte Carlo
methods to sample from a statistical
model what also the logic does not work
that's
okay so since I don't have these I can
just show okay so hopefully
we apply Bayes theorem to compute the
posterior probability of our parameter
given the data now I don't have the
formula here but if you just have in
mind that we have a certain probability
of a number of parameter given the data
by Bayes theorem that is equal to okay
so we have our list of parameters that
is the time point the food for air were
flown in fresh water which means the
mean of the food from before and after
the end of the golfer and each one in
digital society mean of the egt before
and after this theorem is telling us
that the posterior probability it's
essentially the product of the
likelihood that that is the probability
of the data given our parameters them
suppliers the probability of each
parameters now we model this in this way
we have the likelihood here I'm just
considering two parameters we ff1 and
ff2 and these the likelihood will be a
normal distribution that well the mean
is FF before the before the end of the
curve and after the end of the curve the
for the price we have the time stamp the
time point when it happens we don't know
when it happens we for us it can happen
anytime between 71 and 720 remember that
20 seconds window around the vertical
navigation and the mean of the flow
before and after again this is signal we
have certain noise so we give as prior
distribution a normal a normal
distribution with mu equal to the mean
of depending on the data the mean of the
flow that were feeding the data that
were filling the model with when we take
the egt into play we will change our
likelihood to be a product of one
dimensional normal distribution we can
see that the parameter to happen to be
independent to each other and this
essentially it can be easily increased
to multiple dimension we can have this
for one engine for two engines we will
have a similar larger than similar price
this is an example of how things work in
a pion see I'm not gonna go through this
whole line behind this is just to say
that that's the class where I define my
priors probability and the likelihood
essentially as you see for example EDX
represented the the time and it's a
discrete uniform a probability between 1
and here length of the data which will
be twenty sevens I can probably stress
on how you run the model around the
sampling this pi mc2 so here what I do
is creating a class and creating our my
data model just to be all the variables
that are defined in this class if MC you
create a model object and then after
that in MCMC object from where you
simple this case we sample for 10,000
time did seven number 8,000 that is the
pudding period essentially at the end of
the sampling we will have 10,000 samples
for each parameters and we discarded the
first eight thousand and two is the
theming which means essentially its
itself to decrease the autocorrelation
the idea of the Markov chain games him
since the acronym for Markov chain Monte
Carlo is essentially doing a random
working
multi-dimensional space nothing is
really random therefore that can be out
of correlation and we want to do this as
much as possible that
therefore we run our model this running
plot is essentially a flopping function
whether I load the data I clean the data
in the sense that I detect the vertical
navigation and just take the parameters
around those twenty seconds
data points I run my two-dimensional
model with the flow and egt and what I
have is this bunch of Hazama each
astronomy is representing the samples
that I collect after the MCM salon so as
you see there is a very clear difference
between the full flow before and after
as well as digital in this case
sometimes it happens you have that the
posterior probability is just weeks at
16 seconds all the same forces are
converging around that number and this
is because in this case what we have is
that when we look at the full flow
that's the blue line now
there are very steep decrease of these
parameters were for dgt here the scale
approaches for that is it does not give
the best idea but there is a huge
difference between the before and after
but the other question is what happen if
one parameter field we have a musket
array we can give a threshold if more
than not 5% of this data is musket then
we don't want to use that parameter we
that will be contaminating our model in
this case we can just run again our our
our model this is in one dimension we
will just be considering the full flow
if for example dgt phase and these
essentially again the trace is plotted
as historama and this is the same date
as before so it's not a surprise that
again in 16 seconds now the second part
of the model is about prediction we have
a new flight and we don't get if there
is the vertical navigation chronometer
or not we just want to look at the first
5 minutes from the take-off to 7,500
because we know that the end of the
curve must happen in in the first 5
minutes so what we do is running the
MCMC in number of flights
200 in in this distance and we collect
all those samples in order to use them
for debating part now I've run my mother
400 flights and this is the distribution
of the flow before and after as well as
egt before and after and the in the
third line EDX up so the first graph
here the first system it's representing
the end of take off the distribution of
the end of the cover from the
from the take-off point so 30 seconds
after the take-off you so what's the
strategy I will use these samples well
again we apply Bayes theorem so Bayes
theorem is telling us that if I were to
come if I want to check if a data point
is what's the probability that a data
point is the end of the Goff I just have
to compute these products so the
likelihood would be the end of the
coffee even my parameters and the prior
will be even by our prior knowledge on
the parameter that will be the time the
full-flowing digty and precisely the
likelihood will be used will be infrared
from the our history
so in this example we have know we don't
really know when the end of the coffee
it's happening we know that for sure it
cannot land in the first 15 seconds it's
just too early so for the time we have a
discrete uniform distribution between 15
seconds and 304 the flow in digital
again we give a normal driving
distribution for the likelihood we will
use them that we will use the data in in
this case I'm just showing how to out a
probability density function from our
kiss from in this case we use cyber it
starts the Gaussian kernel density
estimation but here we can use
scikit-learn or again we can use another
one of the MCMC again but for production
purposes this is the fastest this is the
fastest and this is an example what
happened for a for a given flight here
that the real end of takeoff is at forty
one seventh and essentially we computed
this probability at each point in time
from the take-off up to five minutes and
we see that the prediction is around the
42 seconds which essentially we can use
also this data to assess some where the
previous model we can run this
prediction algorithm on all the data or
all the flights that we use it to fit
the model and we can have some metrics
to assess that model I'm not showing
that here for
because of the time I guess I'm already
over going so if have any questions
problems and data Sciences alimony
Aladar now and yes for the primacy
reference that is a it's really good
that the the actual documentation of
privacy and I strongly advise you the
base emitters for are kept by camera and
a speedo that is actually also Open
Safina not available
yeah you're talking about detecting
undertaken and G calculate other
features as well and for example
determine the operations or incorrectly
wait it's like you have to increase the
danger velocity higher than your
expected because you know
you have I do this
depending on what you're trying to
achieve
you can do that and there there's thing
called a directed takeoff but in fact
the cruise doesn't set if you can't see
this you can't see the drop in feel for
people going up it just straight line
why they use it there are reasons for
that but the idea is little makes the
long story short as that we will not in
that case be able to probably to detect
this point because we will be fitting
the noise but we can always snap to the
old tradition of hard threshold of 300
seconds and say if you reach 300 seconds
and we will grant are able to detect
that point the same 300 seconds is a
limit and we have another limit is 3500
feet so if you reach 350 feet you should
have going over the Medina order Davis a
very good point yes there are many many
parameters that depend on
yeah it's not about Malaysian plants
does the temporary record also contain
the the quiet voice recorder as well as
the flight data recorder that's a very
good question
I know some people who who tried to do
something with the cockpit voice
recorder but still if that this data is
not being analyzed since we don't use it
probably provide only a couple of files
the problem is that it's very hard to
the identified these flights so and the
key to the key fob is that
you usually don't it week sometimes we
can but sometimes the the identification
is harder than you think because you
can't know by you know knowing a lot
longer but you've no word from each
other but it took off and if you know
the airline if you have just one ever
flying to that Airport agreement
somebody you know who that line
sometimes it's very very hard to do to
do that you said they release it
sometimes in case of accident it's just
in case of that accidents and for
regular maintenance they you think we
take off the no good thing we are also
doing some data sharing programs where
airlines will share their data we don't
have unfortunately factor to talk about
that these are very interesting concepts
but for the sake of flight safety and my
scare group together and share their
data so the pilots have the prior
knowledge of how to fly the plane but if
you could gets into an unknown Airport
he will be able to know the issues
independent so he will be able to
respond to due to the requirement for
landing because it's easy to say land
and air and it's not so easy when it's
dark outside and you have strong winds
blowing
it's challenging it's the peanut bumpy
pressing not recorded at all yes it is
yes
use that tranquillity yes we use the
veena for referencing the point
arrives we start from there to find that
the drop in fuel flow that we detect the
scent of clean everything cries yes this
is just a binary variable of zero one
two why we have many many many more
categorical variables then you know then
we have continuous variables so why did
not seem to be that because sometimes to
be nervous corrupted the valid signal
may be corrupted sometimes it does not
exist at all not on the knot of the
aircraft may have there been important
for me recorded that that signal or the
parameter can be no
okay why is this dataset confidential it
seems like you know you can there are
websites where you can track planes
taking off and landing in real time why
would things like fuel flow be these
super confidential no it's not just a
few for its the data in Europe you have
how many countries and every single
country has a body that regulates the
the safety so you have civil aviation
authorities that's regulate how the data
in whose data is in fact a data Chris
can help me who have in Germany I think
that the pilots all or all the data and
probably to the rest of the Europeans if
it's a pure example say there is a
connection problem so you've got one
operator twice with high fuel flow than
another and suddenly you know that
operators able to compare his operations
I'm not operate and say no well we can
do this Jeep or we can do this
it seems like it might yeah it seems
like this would be a public value just
like commercial no no no they are comfy
well they are open source completely
very respect to safe country and
certainly with respect to safety things
video Kasasa yeah you can download our
algorithms that we've used in production
but the data we don't know the data we
do the parameters and calculations that
we gather from the data so it's it's
readily available but all the
technologies that we use our open source
for space SQL Python I don't know how
all these kinds of things but the data
is catalysis one issue is probably they
you mentioned you don't want to be
blaming Thailand yes so if you open up
the data once both the products makers
do not to blame them yeah yeah but you
just nobody was if you try to fly and
happen and you do not have any pilots
because they they already know that they
have been monitored because we legal
requirement is that they have running
program so now when you start you know
sharing the data across the globe for
the good of it's not an easy process and
they're very traditional in aviation
that's where they have checklists and
the safety is really until your quest
rate I mean yeah we would like to do
that but the only way we can do is to
through the data sharing programs where
they do get voluntary not press it
others other any airlines that today no
no that I know yeah thank you we can
discuss break
thank you very much for coming guys
you